here's the story from Sky News President
Joe Biden Cuts press conference short as
White House confirms Iran actively
facilitating some attacks on US military
bases in Iraq and Syria I just love the
the language how it's so like passive
and
Confused Iran actively facilitating some
attacks okay look is Iran attacking the
us or not I think the issue is they want
to seed the information that's how it
usually happens they want to gear us up
for the moment when they announc troops
are going to be deployed specifically to
fight with Iran we've already seen
members of Congress say they're drafting
an authorization for use of military
force against Iran and their proxies
whatever proxies means and it seems like
this is going to Bubble Up to World War
I on Twitter World War III is trending
here's the clip I want to play this clip
for you it's it's it's quite simple it's
only a few seconds long and when uh
Malcolm Flex has it Biden cuts his
speech short as the attacks are
happening can't confirm if it's casual
or not here we go we got the sound right
I apologize I have to go to the
situation with another issue I have to
deal with but thank you thank you thank
you so that's it it's it's it's rather
uneventful other than to say in the
middle of a press conference he
announced he was going to have to go to
the situation room because uh we've got
these uh this report Malcolm Flex is
tweeting groups with ties to the Iranian
militias claim they've attacked with
rockets three bases in Northeast Syria
al- Omar Al tan and Al shadar could be a
tell as far as where Iran uh uh and
probably Iran loyal militant states in
the area
stand okay well I hope you're all ready
for uh World War II and uh how how you
doing I learned that if you have taken
anti-press or anti-anxiety medication in
the last uh over the last 12 months or
for a cumulative of 36 months in the
last couple years you can't be drafted
so I think a lot of women are not going
to uh be drafted as we head into World
War III so I hope you're ready gen Z
especially there's so much big farm is
going to save the day right well it is
our great hope and savior uh what would
we do without big Pharma that's really
interesting because women don't get
drafted anyway mhm women don't have to
register for Selective Service no they
don't only if you're a man who's dressed
like a woman then you have to register
for selice they haven't gotten around
that loophole yet which is kind of funny
uh yeah well because Biden came there
was a report last year that um the Biden
Administration was saying that uh trans
women do have to register for a
Selective Service M so all you draft
Dodgers that are buying skirts right now
don't worry it's not going to work yeah
just get on the ssris instead well it's
funny because uh I there was this poll
that came out about the Israel Israel
Palestine conflict and I guess 18 to 24
overwhelmingly are in favor of Palestine
and Hamas and I say and Hamas because I
am not trying to say the same thing I'm
actually drawing the distinction many of
these leftists are cheering on Hamas
explicitly that's what I'm trying to
point out you know and it's because of
that
the the US is getting its ever so
desperate CES belly uh with for
Iran the US uh military-- industrial
complex deep State whatever has wanted
war with Iran the entire time I've been
alive all right and so now because of
this fight you know Hamas going into
Israel killing all these civilians
Israel's released footage it's
horrifying footage man some of it's only
been described some of it there is video
they released I watch some of it it's
crazy and now this is the funny thing
the US likes to
do Hamas attacks Israel and so all of a
sudden they're like it you mean Iran we
have to go to war with Iran like no no
no we're talking about Hamas you mean so
so Iran we're going to go we're invading
Iran all right let's send the troops to
Iran it's like oh what okay I guess but
now they're basically saying that all of
this is actually Iran Iran's the one
funding it Iran's the one planning it
it's like okay well then fine I guess
we're going to World War I well Iran was
reported by The Wall Street Journal to
have been in a meeting with Hamas and
Hezbollah just uh the Monday before the
attack saying that um it it was reported
that Iran green lit the attack at that
point and then Iran denied it later but
um Iran has been backing Hamas for a
very long time Iran has been backing
Hamas since like Israel kicked out a
bunch of terrorists and sent them to
Lebanon where they got trained by
Hezbollah and the uh what is it the
Iranian guard what are they called I
forget but um the igf the igf yeah the
igf and they were getting train so Hamas
got trained by Hezbollah and the igf in
Lebanon before they um became Hamas in
the late ' 80s this would mean that
Russia should be declaring war in the
United States explicitly um perhaps
Ukrainian forces are funded armored
trained by us and EU forces and if the
argument from the United States is that
we have to go to war with Iran because
they've trained Hamas then Russia would
need to declare war on the United States
right
this this argument is you know have your
cake and eat it too yeah it's it's the
US's own version of it's okay when we do
it I mean exactly it's ridiculous I mean
I think part of it is that we always
knew there was very slim chance that
this wouldn't expand regionally that
other countries nearb would get involved
and I think you're right with this
headline they're trying to sort of
preemptively set up the argument for why
America needs to get involved in this
war which uh I just don't think is
necessarily the best case scenario for
anyone and I understand that we have
uh allies we have relationships
diplomatic with with Israel and and
everyone else in the region on the other
hand we create all of these problems and
then we say oh but don't worry we'll
come fix it I don't know pron did you do
anything uh exciting when you were in
the Army uh no no I didn't right when I
joined really the coid pandemic hit and
they enforced the co vaccine and that's
kind of why I'm out now so wow yeah so
no I didn't get to do much what was your
like what was your role was your job 88
Mike I was actually going to do green to
Gold where I could enlist to become a
Jag officer that's what the whole plan
was until it got kind of sidest stepped
by the vaccine oh wow well here we are
I'm not I I I wonder that's actually a
really interesting point you bring up
because we're talking about the draft
too but how many good men and women in
uniform left over the the the coid
vaccination and the bigger picture how
how depleted or how how how how far
behind are we in terms of recruitment
goals not just because of the vaccine
but because of wokeness in politics in
general I guess the conspiracy theory is
the reason the US is is allowing all
these people to cross the border into
the country is that they're going to
offer up citizenship to be Frontline
infantry or something which you know I
don't know if that's effective but I do
kind of know anybody who's played any
one of these strategy Video Games like
World of Warcraft or Starcraft or
whatever you just mass-produced the
lowest quality fighter and just non-stop
send them wave after wave after your
enemies you win so like you can have all
the nukes all the Jets all the
satellites you want but if your ground
Army is bigger you win and you know
you're willingness to sacrifice them but
in that capacity the US has technology
but they don't have people sure no they
don't and the the thing about military
recruitment goals is that we've been
behind for a long time so there are
people who left like you're saying
because of uh the co vaccine there are
now also people who will not enlist
because of the co vaccine and so on top
of the issues that we're already having
with a population that is not qualified
to be a part of the military those who
are willing to enlist and who will
enlist is it's just this extremely small
margin I don't like the idea that we
would just be like oh well you came here
illegally but to give you citizenship
we'll let you enlist in the Army I think
that's not a a logical justification but
if you're about to say things are very
desperate we need boots on the ground
you're sort of creating a worst case
scenario and then delivering this
solution that is imperfect in and of
itself well that's kind of the strategy
they use like recruiters use to bring
people into the military uh I know my
recruiters at least would it's kind of
like a running joke on Tik Tok too where
people will go to like a Home Depot and
pick up illegals to join the military
and they'll offer them you know
citizenship so they'll join but just in
my personal experience um all the good
folks all the people who you know were
meant to be in the military there wasn't
a lot of them left and I know that
during my basic training in uh AIT which
is like Advanced Training for your job
um we had
people the the treatment of peoples and
their standards was unbelievable women
were you know like we had some people in
there that were like 5 foot2 couldn't
carry the load for themselves we would
go on Ruck marches that were really 12
miles long and they would end up falling
out and they would get put in a truck
and get driven back and or they couldn't
shoot what you were supposed to shoot
what the standard was and they would
pass them anyway why would they pass
them anyway because they have to fill
these spots just creating Cannon fod
basically this is the other thing that's
happening is that recruitment all of the
numbers are actually off from what I
know from people who are inlisted right
now is that they are using like they are
you shifting data to pad their numbers
because they are so far behind in in
recruitment goals I mean it's not good
but once you get into the army they need
to keep you there so the what I've heard
from a lot of people and this goes back
well before the culture War stuff that
in basic training the men like your your
the the the the clothes they give you
what are the pts is that what they're
called filthy and dirty as you're like
crawling through the mud you don't watch
them you take them off you wake up you
eat as fast as you can you get back to
it the women would cry complain sit down
refuse to walk any further because it
hurts too much and then be told don't
worry it's fine like you mentioned get
truck to drive in the rest of the way
they couldn't carry anything they had
they they they were uh mandated to be
able to get showers and clean clothes
every day and the argument was medical
women have medical reasons where they're
required to have clean clothes and so
the men are being like thrown into the
into the muck and told figure it out and
the women are are being given this this
like hospital fourstar treatment these
are all reasons that I never would have
joined the military well and they also I
like showers and clean clothes no no you
get them women get them men don't that's
that's ridiculous they got complacent
with like the low standards a lot of the
girls and they would literally walk the
two mile runs well what what I was told
is that if they tell the women you can't
for a shower it's discrimination based
on sex because women have special needs
and so they have to get showers and then
they shouldn't be allowed to join the
military if and if and if they hold the
women at the same standards as the men
well that's sexist because men and women
are different even though now the
argument is that men and women aren't
different if you look at the uh which is
it is it the bck decision if you look at
the bow decision it's sexual
discrimination to not give the men
showers yeah but to give the women
showers it would be that would be discri
that's discriminatory well the point is
whenever everybody gets showers on the
battlefield come on Tim anything that
doesn't benefit the left is
discrimination until it benefits them
then it's bounced so like if the if you
say they'll come out they'll say men and
women are the same there for you know
trans people should be in women's sports
everyone should be equal and then you go
okay military training equality that's
not fair men and women are different
women can't care as much as men so they
get special treatment you just men men
and women weren't different I say
they're different so the issue is the
left simultaneously argues both
positions this is why I often say
there's no morality on the left there is
none yeah the left does not have a moral
position they have a give me power yeah
so in the military women don't run not
all of them you know some women do but
right you know so so this is this an
interesting point about where we're
currently at in recruitment goals it's
probably worse than we realize the
military is probably a whole bunch of
like 22-year-old women with two moms
yeah I think it's that's in their
advertising that's that's they'll throw
a bonus at you $2,000 to join but their
standards are ridic and I even had a
girl in front of me on one March
specifically and she was crying because
the the load was too much for her to
carry she was again like 5 fo2 so I
tried to like lift her Ru sack up with
my hands the whole way there but it's
like you can't have that kind of like
situation on the battlefield you know
and so I just think it's kind of sad
that that's where we've gotten to as a
country I've heard arguments before that
they need to revisit some of their
standards like this thing about anxiety
medication right like if you have taken
anxiety medication during these
parameters you're disqualified for
military service so it means that some
people just don't report it or you know
I've heard a lot of um Special Forces
people say I just lied I lied my way
through it because I wanted really badly
to make it and I am qualified other than
these sort of you know rules they felt
were arbitrary but in some cases you
know the idea of being battle ready is
very important and I think we saw this
with you know letting women in the
military the physical standard which
they expected to to meet has to be
lowered because women are different
biologically and physiologically than
men and so ultimately in pursuit of what
we think is best at home are we actually
putting people in Foreign Fields in a
battle ready situation where the people
around them can protect them I just
don't think so well and also that
shouldn't really be what's going on in a
battlefield everyone should be there to
do their best and not need to be
protected by their peers the other thing
though is like I think it's normal to
have people looking out for each other
when yeah you look out for each other
but like you can't look out for someone
who can't look out for you for sure you
know like if the 5 foot2 woman who can't
carry her own pack like how's she going
to look after Preston she not that's the
problem so you're not allowed to have
taken ssris and anxiety medication for a
certain period of time but you are
allowed to be taking cross- sex hormones
no no no no no no no no no they give you
the crossx arm oh they give you those of
course that's the benefit Sig up like
your rations thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net